[Musica]
gli occhi sono pa vj io faccio con
gameplay mi vedete col cappello ma dici
quanto è bello ma perché cesto cappello
fa vj day a te lo dico io gioco a scribe
punto io volevo fare un video con i miei
capelli ma fra te credimi non sono belli
allora metto il cappello scrive il punto
io con i miei ragazzi buona visione
e in italiano qui dobbiamo scrivere in
italiano e da vi voglio bene ciao
[Musica]
cos'è
e vai vai astino un'amica prevedo una
partita veramente difficile è un cerchio
veramente bello se posso terribile
sentirebbero come no
esatto sembrava niente ma cosa morgan
freeman 85 parole parole casi sbaglio le
tre mi sono un po randomiche ad essere
merito con anche qua perché secondo me
sta bene allora appaiarsi dietro ci
dicano tutto con le frecce credo che un
mese perché stavano bene cioè per dare
prospettiva latina erano ben bravo luca
meno male che vuoi
tutti abbiamo provato big bang è una
grande madonna comunque l'orologio più
brutto che abbia mai visto dai pure le
onomatopee per maroni ha capito ho
capito la roma
no no ho capito però è perché è ovvio ma
conosco ragazzi incredibile ore si
scrive o pallonari disegno di nuovo
scusa si capisce meglio sicuramente
adesso forse beh questo earth is me non
si può fare sta roba
e questo non è non mi questo dai palese
palese alla massa di massa da ben sa
come mazza da baseball a scrivermi
significa facile dai avuto dagli
evidenti problemi mai amiche c'è ma come
si muove banca perché sei stato
bravissimo
non è la fatica anche
simini modo noi è un pollice con le
gambe ai con le ali e comunque ma dove
vive questo caso lega invece arrivava
pegaso fine chi sembrava finita lì
voleva come questo è difficile lega non
solo me disegnarlo potevi fare una
capanna invece da tecnicamente arrivato
per caso siete imbattibili cioè non so
che dire veramente c'è competizione vero
la radio come si scrive con l'aics è un
super con le sopracciglie lodo detto è
molto semplice però dentro
mamma mia che con i miei disegni
indovinate tutti grande loro ultimo
perché sono astemio scusa non vi dico
che cosa mi sembra la vedo io la
indovinata perché mi è capitato prima
ok ci penso io ragazza allora questo è
facile a questo fatevi intesi a dritta
non importa immaginate cosa può essere
ma come ma cosa c'è scritto il libro ii
libro ma non è vero che ci siamo scritti
va bene
e bellissimo libro che si chiama il
libro ma non c'è molto ma che hai fatto
dei cambi one ha ben nove sincronia
anche se è così ma è una gamba sola
quella hai disegnato niente sbagliato
tutto scordio e animano adesso su un al
bar on
belletti cosa iscritto la di rame ferro
mossa di pokémon dai quello che ci sono
poche le montagne la più semplice
bullismo non ci credo è la prima parte
che esiste è la più base che esiste
nelle ge è una gilera è proprio quella
che ci hanno tutti i pokémon allora la
scusa mimì compare nell
proprio lui
[Risate]
bellissima ma stasera è la prima le navi
che sia dai nave pirata è quasi
recuperato salami 6 english man compagni
che primo simone biello madonna di
ballata bar capacità ma un secondo prima
sempre ma che bello che fanno un po dark
un po centrista questo ma col papa sta
di mare abbiamo provato di bega su
unicorno animali dal male la tecnica
sembrava una tartaruga con la varicella
che cazzo mi devo dire amore vero
no quella è la più brutta bandiera
dell'america che io abbia mai visto
tutto questo se fosse sincera presidente
per questo dritto e non sembra un telaio
juan ma non mi fermo mai così si
affiderà porca vacca troppi punti
allora forse siete conquista e
recuperando vale detto sono distanti di
niente allora i punti
questa difficile
forza ma così a regolarlo perché no
perché impossibile
e giusto la volata lo ami che l'ultima
parola non mi fare perdere questo avanti
40 punti allora dietro un braccio per 26
ma cos'è ma come ha fatto a 0 devi farne
un po più easy però va bene lo stesso ma
così chiaro si poteva farlo decisamente
più denso seria
se hai fatto realmente vecchio meno
reale mi sento dentro la cassa toracica
è un tumore al colon
vero ma che non ho capito perché il meta
marrone metà rosso concentrico scusa
della matrioska incredibile è stata una
bellissima partita ragazzi complimenti
quindi ragazzi questa squadra io e noi
ci vediamo un prossimo episodio ne
faremo diversi perché la mia crew come
vedete abbastanza stupida da poter
permettere più video schiacciato mi
piace che mi aiutate fortemente sempre
lasciato anche un commentino come sempre
ragatzu alice via al prossimo video
ragazzi
[Musica]